hey guys how's it going happy holidays
welcome back to my kitchen for another
fun-filled cooking episode in this
episode we're going to make gingerbread
cookies because it's the holidays and
gingerbread is real festive but to make
it even more festive these are gonna be
xbox controller gingerbread cookies i
bought these cookie cutters years ago
never even used them so today we put
them to use
all right so my original recipe that i
looked up for the ingredients
well apparently i can't find it anymore
so some of the ingredients that i need
for this recipe i don't have so we're
just gonna kind of wing it let's get a
let's get some things
prepared
what do we have in here okay i got my
pans
i could really use like some rachel ray
style stuff where this is all set out
for me really nicely measured three and
one-fourths cup of flour so three cups
and also a one-fourth that's about
that's about one looks good to me two
three now one fourth
you expect me to measure that no that's
about one-fourth a three-fourths
teaspoon get open
oh
potentially more than i need room
temperature soft
softened really
okay it's not soft i didn't get the memo
it was in the fridge where it belongs
in you go
i need a half cup of dark brown sugar i
have brown sugar so i use regular sugar
tablespoon of ground ginger tablespoon
here we go
that's a tablespoon
cinnamon we even have ground nutmeg in
here
okay oh no
i almost put zesty seasoning blend in
not a good idea
is that a tablespoon yet
i don't think i'm supposed to actually
be putting this all in yet no
okay this is going to be too much work i
don't think i want to do this anymore
ground cloves
the heck is a ground clove
okay ground cloves
in you go how much was i supposed to put
it half teaspoon that's definitely a
half teaspoon then smells real good
let's put a little more in
i think it needs more half teaspoon of
ground nutmeg somebody warned me on my
vlog not to use too much ground nutmeg
half tisp
good enough
is that good
i forgot to put my sugar in oops in you
go
finely ground black pepper why would i
put pepper in a freaking whatever
do i need an egg or anything wait a
minute i don't even need an egg i think
i should put an egg in here you don't
necessarily need an egg
but i like them then throw an egg
there's nothing that an egg is gonna do
that you're not gonna mess up more than
the egg
what are you saying
what the wait a minute it says i have to
chill for at least an hour or overnight
uh-uh for us last minute christmas
cookie makers
this is crap
i think we've made some mistakes already
we've only just begun we're gonna have
to blend it because i don't know what
else to do to be honest with you they
want me stop it your shut your mouth
they want me to refrigerate this after
rolling this out like you're drunk
you're drunk this is how we do it i
don't even know what day it is we're
gonna blend up our dry ingredients
stop it's hammer time i don't i just
don't believe that i don't need an egg
like i'm like actually quite upset about
this in goes our butter if you're
following along at home it's best that
you just don't even bother
oh
shoot
come on you can do this
you can do this
it smells like dough some say
you can't do things well i say why not
do it anyway this needs an egg i'm
extremely
adamant about this
like who's gonna tell me i'm wrong no
one
the internet
hmm maybe it needs another egg maybe i
need a mixer for christmas
i think no because i like to blend it's
part of the charm
you're not cooking
okay all right
about some heavy whipping cream this is
gonna be for the eggnog but we can put a
little bit of this in here right
all right well i have blended to the
best of my abilities i'm now gonna put
it back in this bowl
freaking happy new year looks good to me
no it doesn't
list
help me
not gonna lie to you i think that this
is gonna be one of my best pieces
of meal i've ever made all right as much
as i didn't wanna resort to looking at
the directions again i'm gonna just take
a little peek okay add sugar oh shoot i
forgot the molasses
that's kind of important i think
molasses is a very crucial part a half
cup i have to get
in here it's like a crucial part
that's about a half cup right i can't
believe this
this is depressing
worthless
we're gonna have to go in do some some
squishing around here
i think we need some more flour baby
i don't even know what to do
okay we i have to i have to do this
what's up
this is what i have to do
oh
mixer and it won't blend
okay
we're about done here i think
we're gonna have tie-dye cookies
so
this is just awful
absolutely awful
yeah something's not right a lot of
things aren't right with this just some
extra flowers
hanging out oh boy i won't even roll out
i just need to at least get one single
cookie out of this and i will be a happy
camper it's just falling apart
i think we have one one single cookie
one cookie
maybe i should have chilled maybe a lip
no no there will be no chilling the only
chilling i'm gonna do is with this and a
cup of
hot milk
we have two
perfect perfect fit i managed to get at
least three cookies so let's put these
in the oven
and see what happens
huh here goes everything it's almost
time for decoration the cookies are
cooking and i'm gonna prepare our icing
it says to cut this cap off i don't have
scissors so we're going to use this
only there
come here
oh my gosh
look at these
i'm so sorry i thought it would be nice
to do a little outline little outline
here of the uh controller
almost like i'm a professional i should
open my own bakery
okay here you go
it's gonna look a little something like
that what do you think so far oh my that
these don't look well it looks good
though it does really oh my god
hey you want to come in here and give it
a little taste test it's so terrible
it's so
awful i think the only thing that can
save this are peppermint chips
hi
would you like to try one of them
look how cute those xbox controllers are
yeah look guys
they look really delicious
cheese you kind of like a marble
look going there i call it tie dye
i don't want one with a button okay i'm
gonna how about i just take a little
they're a little thick but really good
real good
guy
better
put him right there
i don't know i just hate dinner but i'm
a little nauseous right now
maybe
i'll just put this
this bite just just to save it
have a holy jolly
of christmas year
oh
the mistletoe
i think we're done you have a cup of
cheese thank you guys so much for
watching i'm really sad that this didn't
work out as well as i had planned but
stay tuned because i'm also going to be
making eggnog because that's a
holiday drink i've never actually had
eggnog before i lied i had it at
starbucks once an eggnog latte and it
kind of sucked but maybe i don't like
eggnog we're gonna find out happy
holidays i'll see you guys in the next
video peace
out